[Music]
what is happening there reject nation
greg and john just got out of the
screening for doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness okay so the first
thing i got to give a disclaimer for is
that almost every second of this movie
is a spoiler
you mean that literally
like every second of this movie's a
spoiler here's what i'm gonna do i
pulled up the plot description for this
film dr steven strange casts a forbidden
spell that opens a portal to the
multiverse however a threat emerges that
may be too big for his team to handle
now we've seen a lot of tv spots in a
lot of trailers there's a lot of plot
yeah yes you're not gonna get in those
trailers or that logo line for us for
that matter we're gonna keep this
non-spoilery obviously our spoiler talk
we will be doing live stream we're
aiming for it this sunday so cancel
plans with your mother on mother's day
and come hang out with us instead john
coy jondro it's gonna be a really fun
time here's what i'll kick this off with
this movie's called multiverse of
madness is it madness
i bet your goddamn ass is madness
you gotta wake up with ptsd after this
really crazy yeah you're damn right they
were crazy am i mad am i going mad i
must be going mad no it's not perfect
the film's not perfect the movie's
perfect rico why don't you just say that
i hate that criticism i get it i've
heard i've heard you guys say that about
anything i've ever said that about
before ever some criticisms that i feel
like we might be able to dive into
without going into spoilers but let's
leave with all the things that are
positive about it because there's so
many things that are overwhelmingly
positive about it first things first
this is a sam raimi film this is not oz
the great and the powerful where you
slap sam raimi's name on there and
you're like it's kind of a sam raimi
film but it feels like they held them
back a little bit there were times where
i was like we are watching the other
side of town in his spider-man world
where doctor strange is having a fight
at times as you've seen the trailer that
straight up remind you of his work from
like evil dead and drag me to hell the
camera work they really
let him be a visual storyteller i want
to say this is my favorite marvel movie
i would not go there with that however
it was pretty early on where i was just
thinking this is one of the most
exciting marvel movies i've ever seen
it's probably the most visually dazzling
marvel movie
we've ever seen yeah it is crazy and
just how much they just let him do his
thing the amount of gasps throughout the
audience the amount of applause would
just this just i i can't explain imagine
what you saw in the trailers all the
weirdness times that by 10 and then
forget everything you know because
you're never gonna even come close to
understanding what i'm getting at here
because it is insane it lives up to the
title in the best possible way would you
agree john i would absolutely agree and
i think that not only does his style
really suit the piece and it doesn't
feel like sam raimi is at odds with the
movie at all or not it does deliver i
think a leveling up of some of the
intensity especially just within certain
images and certain deeds done and
depicted in terms of the marvel
cinematic universe there are certain
things that are actually kind of
shocking in a way i was not expecting
this movie to go to in a horror kind of
setting so yeah very much pleased by
that and it feels appropriately sinister
and mystical and sort of outside the
realm like i think they're doing a
really nice job of differentiating the
godlike characters from the masters of
the mystical arts and the magicians and
the witches and whatnot and then you
know your traditional sort of inhumans
or or you know super serum injected
characters like they do really have a
great grip on that sort of occultish end
of the mcu and it gets pretty demonic at
points in a way i was kind of surprised
by this movie was just pure popcorn
entertainment it has that wonderful camp
and cheese that is just so damn charming
and it's so effective at times maybe not
the most effective but most of the time
it's pretty awesome shocking at times
arguably the most imaginative this feels
like a dr strange comic book come to
life i really like benedict cumberbatch
a lot in this movie i would say that the
one who stole the show was wanda like i
think
wow like she's such a presence yeah they
keep a lot of her story out of the
promos for this and she's great it picks
up after wanda vision there's been a
little bit of time jump with their
character
let's just keep it at that
find out for yourself they definitely
are building upon it and segwaying right
out of that into this so brush up on one
division if you haven't seen it yeah
because i think if you haven't seen one
division they you know they give you
like a recap and that's part of the
issue that i kind of have with this film
and i'll dive into that in a second
elizabeth olsen does something so
different here than what she did in
wanda vision and yet still steals the
show yeah absolutely it didn't even take
adjusting actually no i was like no this
is yeah
yeah
this is great stuff man yeah keep it
coming i really like what she's doing
zoshi gomez is also very excellent in
this film i was really endeared to her
character are there cameos you guys know
there's cameos
and
multiverses
[Music]
i found out that some of them are on the
internet so avoid it stay offline boss
please
they know what they're doing in this
movie they do what they do and they know
how to make it so hard to talk about
what they're doing
let's say there's some good horror in
the film there's some amazing action a
lot of moments that truly generate
applause worthy stuff you know i'll say
this too uh i i'm usually much more of a
reserved audience member at a theater to
be respectful but i i was i was pretty
vocal in all
ranges of emotion for
a lot of this film throughout so yeah
it's a damn good crowd film for sure
even rachel mcadams returning in this
film is pretty freaking solid i think i
enjoyed her more than i did in the first
doctor strange movie i would agree some
things that i think are are kind of
issues for me this really wasn't an
issue for me in the first like 20 to 30
minutes of the film i was like i don't
think i've ever seen a marvel movie like
this so entertaining in the first leg
this is so entertaining yeah the movie
constantly moves really fast but the
thing i would liken it to and this is
this is gonna sound worse than it
actually sounds and i'm not just saying
this to be nice but this is the only
thing i could really think of right now
to give a a basis for how i would liken
it without spoiling things you know when
you don't watch those dc shows but you
want to see the crossover event so you
watch the crossover event and it's like
super fast-paced super quick it's kind
of like a bunch of exposition non-stop
this movie felt like it needed 20 20
more minutes it felt like that to me but
a darker
better version of that it was definitely
rushed at times and at times it is like
messy and not in the way that feels
intentional there are times where it is
just like there's too much going on to
me ultimately i was still left going
this could have used an extra 20 to 30
minutes to breathe it really could
happen and then other times it needed
that pacing like this movie excels a lot
of the time in the pacing that it's
doing and then other times i'm like i
kind of wish it was slow down in various
scenes when it does slow down and when
it does indulge in the emotional
journeys of the characters that are
running alongside this i kept finding
myself going oh yeah it's a good scene i
like this let's let's do more of this
and i do wish they had balanced the
movie out with more of that kind of
stuff because it does especially with
certain characters start to feel like
okay you're just here for some
exposition and that's kind of all we
have time for and your emotional arc is
a little perfunctory hey warren are you
talking about america chavez i'm talking
about america's shopping yeah because
american shop is sochi gomez elevates
the role but i think that about america
is like multiverse of reactions the
characterizations and the character
journeys you know the emotional stuff
that isn't the first thing you think of
when you come into these movies is
something that is a little bit more
lacking and i don't want to sound like a
broken record but it's one of those
things where you look at the shows and
you look at the movies and you go damn
the benefit is we have all that time to
dive into the characters and while i
liked the emotional journey they had
laid out for doctor strange i liked what
happened christine palmer back did for
that story as well and it's just all
stuff i wanted more from and i wanted to
be more affected by it's like there's
good work and there's some good writing
but it's not what gets the focus and i
think that it makes some of the again
emotional payoffs feel a bit perfunctory
or feel a bit like oh you know the plot
requires that
instead of letting you live within the
building of certain relationships or the
letting go of certain traumas or the you
know coming to face with your legacy in
a you know multiversal kind of way yeah
it's like part of the point is it's
supposed to be madness there's a way to
make chaos
feel
smooth and natural and other times
you're like nah i really think this
needed like 20 more minutes yeah it's
like there's madness in the in the
plotting and then the things that are
happening and i wanted to feel more of
the madness and it's there in fits and
bursts but i wanted to feel the
emotional madness throughout yeah i
think the reason why i felt that way is
because even though it was like full of
that wonderful sam raimi aesthetic and
and tone overall a lot of scenes like
looked wonderfully gothic or horror
centric yet for some reason the film
seemed to lack in suspense and when it
seemed like it was really going for that
but it was always fun though that was
the thing that really made up for it and
how fun it was and there's just so many
scenes and so much information a lot of
it is just mainly following like plot
points and reveals and there are things
that might be plot holes i'm not sure
any second viewing it's really hard to
explain it because there's so much
that's not in the trailer so that would
spoil the film the stuff that i'm
talking about it's not in the trailers
it's like there in the beginning of the
movie
i can't go into it because the trailer's
plain and simple don't make it clear
overall though i would say that this
movie is very entertaining a lot about
the writing i did find myself desiring
more however because of the fact that it
was just such a visually exciting film
and because how wanda was so cool in
this movie and i'll say man i know the
movie was effective to the point where
there would be these things that
happened later on in the film that i was
like oh yeah i forgot the trailer showed
you that snippet of that scene a lot of
times you know you kind of go where's
that scene that we saw on the trailer
waiting for it and i would completely
forget about it so it was effective
danny elfman score awesome in this film
overall i did leave going like i can't
wait to watch that again on imax like
this is a theater going exciting
experience absolutely and because
there's so much in it like i'm really
excited to see how a second viewing
changes the experience and what i like
more or just as much or less depending
on that you know but yeah guys thanks so
much for being here um subscribe can you
look out for our spoiler talk what are
you looking forward to most about this
movie talk with you guys soon